>> Tucker: LAST NIGHT WAS OUR
FIRST SHOW OF THE YEAR.
WE DECIDED TO TAKE A MINUTE TO
TALK ABOUT THE BIGGEST ISSUE
FACING THIS COUNTRY GOING
FORWARD.
NO, IT IS NOT HIGHER GDP GROWTH
DESPITE WHAT SOME THINK TANK
PEOPLE WILL TELL YOU.
IT IS NOT SOME OBSCURE MIDDLE
EASTERN HELL HOLE WE SHOULD BE
POLICING FOREVER ANY CLAIM.
IT IS NOT ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION,
AS BIG A PROBLEM IS THAT.
THE REAL PROBLEM IS FAMILIES.
AMERICA USED TO BE THE BEST
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD FOR
FAMILIES.
AMERICANS COULD GET MARRIED AND
AFFORD TO RAISE THEIR OWN
CHILDREN.
IF YOUR KIDS WORKED HARD, YOU
COULD EXPECT THEY WOULD BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL THAN YOU WERE.
THAT WAS CALLED THE AMERICAN
DREAM.
FOR A SMALL GROUP OF AFFLUENT
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE STILL LIVING LIKE IT IS
1965.
GOOD FOR THEM.
FOR EVERYONE ELSE, THAT DREAM IS
DYING.
AMERICA'S MIDDLE CLASS IS IN
DECLINE, BECAUSE MIDDLE CLASS
AMERICAN FAMILIES ARE DECLINING.
THE QUESTION IS, WHY STLA
HAPPENING?
A MAJOR DRIVER OF FAMILY
COLLAPSE, THE ONE NOBODY EVER
TALKS ABOUT FOR SOME REASON IS
SIMPLE ECONOMICS.
WE EXPLAINED IT LAST NIGHT.
>> STUDY AFTER STUDY HAS SHOWN
THAT WHEN MEN MAKE LESS THAN
WOMEN, WOMEN GENERALLY DON'T
WANT TO MARRY THEM.
MAYBE THEY SHOULD WANT TO MARRY
THEM BUT THEY DON'T.
OVER BIG POPULATIONS, THIS
CAUSES A DROP IN MARRIAGE, A
SPIKE IN OUT OF WEDLOCK BIRTHS
AND THE FAMILIAR DISASTERS THAT
FOLLOW, MORE DRUG AND ALCOHOL
ABUSE, HIGHER INCARCERATION
RATES AND FEWER FAMILIES FORMED
IN THE NEXT GENERATION.
LET'S BE CLEAR.
FIRST OF ALL, IT IS FACTUALLY
TRUE.
THAT'S THE ESSENTIAL TEST OF
ANYTHING.
IN 2015, A STUDY BY THE
DECIDEDLY NONCONSERVATIVE
BROOKINGS INSTITUTION FOUND THAT
FALLING MALE WAGES CAUSED A
QUARTER OF THE DECLINE IN
MARRIAGE RATES OVER THE PAST 35
YEARS.
TWO YEARS LATER, MIT RESEARCHERS
FOUND THAT WHEN FACTORIES CLOSE,
MARRIAGE RATES GO DOWN AND
SINGLE PARENTHOOD BECOMES MORE
COMMON.
THAT CAUSES A HIGHER PROPORTION
OF CHILDREN TO WIND UP ON DRUGS
OR IN PRISON.
IT IS NOT A SMALL THING.
MANY OTHER STUDIES HAVE REACHED
THE SAME CONCLUSIONS OVER LONG
PERIODS OF TIME.
THIS IS REAL.
SO WHAT WE SAID IS A STATEMENT
OF FACT.
WE WISH IT WEREN'T.
IN AN IDEAL WORLD, NONE OF THIS
WOULD MATTER.
THE MARRIAGE RATE NEVER WOULD
HAVE DECLINED WHEN MANUFACTURING
DIED AND EVERYTHING IN MIDDLE
AMERICA WOULD BE FINE BUT IT IS
NOT.
WE ARE NOT IN CHARGE OF THAT.
ALL WE DID WAS TELL THE TRUTH OF
WHAT HAPPENED.
THAT TURNED OUT TO BE TOO MUCH
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT BELIEVE IT
IS THEIR JOB TO PREVENT YOU FROM
KNOWING WHY YOUR COUNTRY IS
GOING DOWN THE TUBES.
THOSE PEOPLE GOT VERY ANGRY.
HERE IS A SELECTION.
>> IT REMINDS ME OF WHEN THEY
BLAMED WOMEN FOR PREGNANCY AS IF
HE HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH IT.
>> THIS WOMAN IN THE AUDIENCE,
SHE IS LIKE, WHAT?
>> THIS IDEA THAT, YOU KNOW, TO
KEEP WOMEN DOWN.
>> THAT'S GOING ON IN THE
COUNTRY.
THAT'S ANOTHER ASPECT OF IT.
>> IT LOOKED LIKE LOONY TOWN TO
ME.
>> Tucker: YEAH, LOONY TOWN.
NO ONE CONTESTED THE FACTS OF
WHAT WE SAID.
ONE OF THE SAME HOSTS ADMITTED
THAT, IN FACT, WOMEN DO STRONGLY
PREFER MARRYING MEN WHO MAKE
MORE THAN THEY DO.
IT IS TRUE BUT IT IS NOT ON THE
LIST OF APPROVED TALKING POINTS
SO IT CAN'T EVER BE SAID OUT
LOUD.
THOSE ARE THE RULES AND ANYONE
THAT VIOLATES THOSE RULES MUST
BE PUNISHED.
THIS IS VERY COMMON.
IF YOU ARE WONDERING HOW WE
WOUND UP IN THE DARK AGE WE ARE
CURRENTLY LIVING THROUGH, THIS
IS HOW WE DID.
THIS IS WHY IMPORTANT SCIENCE IS
NO LONGER BEING CONDUCTED.
THIS IS WHY ART ISN'T BEING
MADE.
THIS IS WHY COMEDY IS DYING.
PEOPLE AREN'T THINKING FOR
THEMSELVES.
THIS MEANS THE END OF
CREATIVITY.
THE REST OF US STAND BY LIKE COW
WARDS AS THE INNOCENT ARE
PUNISHED FOR CRIMES THEY DIDN'T
COMMIT, BECAUSE WE ARE ALL
TERRIFIED, TERRIFIED OF BEING
DENOUNCED BY SOME MINDLESS EYE
DIO LOGON TV OR SHAMED AND
OSTRACIZED FOR STEPPING OUT OF
LINE OR SILENCED COMPLETELY BY
SOME BIG TECH FIRM.
A MOB OF ANGRY CHILDREN IS
SUDDENLY IN CHARGE OF THE
COUNTRY.
THESE AREN'T PEOPLE SEEKING A
REVOLUTION BUT FIGHTING FOR THE
STATUS QUO TO PROTECT THEIR OWN
STATUS.
THEY ARE DRUNK ON POWER AND THEY
ARE LOOKING FOR NEW PEOPLE TO
HURT.
SOMEDAY, WE ARE GOING TO LOOK
BACK ON THIS MOMENT WITH SHAME
AND HORROR.
IN THE MEANTIME, WE SHOULD
REMEMBER THAT TERROR ONLY WORKS
IF WE PLAY ALONG WITH IT.
WHAT IF WE DECIDED NOT TO.
WHAT IF ALL OF US DECIDED TO
TELL THE TRUTH ABOUT SOMETHING
EVERY DAY IN PUBLIC.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN THEN?
WHAT COULD THEY DO ABOUT IT?
THEY CAN'T PUNISH EVERYBODY.
WE ARE THE MAJORITY.
LET'S TRY THAT.
WE ARE STARTING TONIGHT WITH
HEATHER McDONALD, A FEARLESS
PERSON, A FELLOW AT THE
MANHATTAN INSTITUTE AND THE
AUTHOR OF "THE DIVERSITY
DELUSION" HOW RACE AND PANIC
DISRUPT OUR COUNTRY.
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR COMING ON,
HEATHER.
MY THEORY IS, WHEN YOU SAY THE
TRUE THINGS, PEOPLE GET
OUTRAGED, A HURT DOG BARKS.
AS A SOCIAL SCIENTIST YOURSELF,
I HOPE YOU WILL CONFIRM THIS IS
NOT A CONTROVERSIAL STATEMENT.
MALE IMEMPLOYMENT AND WAGES
DIRECTLY AFFECT THE MARRIAGE
RATE, DO THEY NOT?
>> FIRST OF ALL, I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU FOR MAKING THE
BREAKDOWN OF MARRIAGE A CENTRAL
FOCUS.
THERE IS NO BIGGER SOCIAL
CATASTROPHE OF OUR AGE THAN THE
FACT THAT MORE AND MORE CHILDREN
ARE BEING RAISED WITHOUT THEIR
FATHERS.
THE ELITES UNDERSTAND THAT.
MARRIAGE HAS NOT DISAPPEARED
FROM THE ELITES.
>> Tucker: THAT'S FOR SURE.
>> YET, THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY
UNWILLING TO SEND THE MESSAGE
THAT FATHERS ARE AS IMPORTANT TO
THEIR CHILDREN AS MOTHERS.
THEIR TONGUES ARE TIED.
THEY REFUSE TO SAY IT.
IT IS ONE OF THOSE TRUTHS THAT
IS, AGAIN, BEING COMPLETELY
DENIED BY THE CULTURE.
WHY?
BECAUSE IT VIOLATES THE FEMININE
NOS STRUM THAT STRONG WOMEN CAN
DO IT ALL.
THERE IS AN ECONOMIC COMPONENT.
WILLIAM JULIUS WILSON EXPLAINED
THE DROP IN MARRIAGE AMONG THE
BLACK COMMUNITY AS A RESULT OF
JOBS LEAVING THE MIDWEST AND HE
SAID THAT THE MALE UNEMPLOYMENT
DECREASES FEMALE'S WILLINGNESS
TO MARRY.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT A CULTURE
EXPLANATION.
I REMEMBER BEING TAKEN AROUND IN
A RIDE-ALONG BY A CHICAGO COP, A
VERY HANDSOME MAN, SOLID JOB,
GOOD PENSION TO LOOK FORWARD TO.
HE HAD FATHERED SEVERAL CHILDREN
OUT OF WEDLOCK.
WHY?
BECAUSE THE MARRIAGE NORM SIMPLY
DISAPPEARED FROM THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
THIS IS A CULTURAL MATTER AND A
PRODUCT TO A CERTAIN EXTENT TO
THE FEMINIST ATTACK ON MALES.
WE ARE LIVING THROUGH A PERIOD
WHERE MALES ARE BEING CONSTANTLY
DISPARAGED AS SIMPLY THE SOURCE
OF EVIL IN OUR WORLD AND THEY
ARE RESPONDING TRAGICALLY BY
WITHDRAWING FROM COMPETITION,
TAKING THEIR MARBLES AND GOING
HOME AND THAT IS LEACHING US ALL
AT GREATER RISK.
>> Tucker: IN SOME CASES, TAKING
THEIR OWN LIVES, I WOULD SAY.
THE SUICIDE RATE FOR AMERICAN
MEN IS HIGHER THAN IT HAS BEEN
IN A LONG TIME.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT THE
PROBLEMS THAT WILLIAM JULIUS
WILSON CHRONICLED SO WELL 30 OR
40 YEARS AGO ARE NOW THE
PROBLEMS OF RURAL AMERICA, WHICH
OBVIOUSLY HAS A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT RACIAL DEMOGRAPHIC AND
POLITICAL BELIEFS THAT INNER
CITY AMERICA.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WHEN IT
HAPPENS TO TWO DIFFERENT GROUPS,
THE VERY SAME THING, THAT WOULD
BE THE WAKEUP CALL FOR OUR
POLICYMAKERS TO SAY, WAIT A
SECOND.
MAYBE WE SHOULD GET INVOLVED IN
THINKING ABOUT HOW TO FIX THIS
CONSIDERING IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
WHERE RICH PEOPLE LIVE IN MY
NEIGHBORHOOD, THERE ARE NO
SINGLE MOTHERS.
EVERYBODY IS MARRIED, BECAUSE IT
WORKS.
WHY AREN'T THEY DOING THEIR BEST
TO PASS ON THE THING THAT IS
WORKING FOR THEM?
IT SEEMS GROTESQUE FOR ME.
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
INDUSTRIAL POLICY AND MAKE SURE
THERE ARE GOOD, WELL-PAYING
JOBS.
I JUST WOULDN'T ASSUME THAT THAT
IS GOING TO BE ENOUGH AT THIS
POINT TO TURN AROUND THE
CULTURE.
AGAIN, WE NEED TO VALUEIZE
MALES.
THERE ARE MALE VIRTUES OF
VALOUR, COURAGE, CIVILRY,
HEROISM IN WAR THAT ARE REALLY
UNIQUELY MALE.
THEY SHOULD NOT BE DISPARAGED.
FEMALES HAVE COMPLEMENTARY
VIRTUES AND VALUES THAT ARE ALSO
ESSENTIAL TO CHILDREN.
>> Tucker: WHERE DOES THE IDEA
COME FROM THAT WHEN MEN FAIL,
WOMEN WIN?
THAT REALLY IS THE UNDERLYING
ASSUMPTION OF THE DUMB PEOPLE WE
ALWAYS PLAY FROM OTHER SHOWS.
MEN ARE DECLINING.
THIS IS GREAT FOR US.
MEN AND WOMEN ARE TOTALLY
INTERCONNECTED.
HOW CAN THE FAILURE OF ONE HELP
THE OTHER?
DOESN'T IT HURT ALL OF US?
>> IT IS A PREPOSTEROUS ZERO SUM
MENTALITY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF FEMALES WHO
ARE ANGRY, ANGRY FOR NO REASON
AT ALL.
THEY HAVE AN AXE TO GRIND, A
CHIP ON THEIR SHOULDER.
THEY ARE CONSTANTLY LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO FEEL OFFENDED, MOSTLY BY
DREDGING UP SEXISM FROM THE
PAST, BECAUSE IT IS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND TODAY.
YOU HAVE FEMALES THAT ARE
EXCELLING IN EDUCATION.
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE MAINSTREAM
INSTITUTION THAT IS NOT TWISTING
ITSELF INTO KNOTS TO HIRE AND
PROMOTE AS MANY FEMALES AS
POSSIBLE.
YET, FEMALES ARE STILL RINGING
THEIR HANDS OVER THE ALLEGED
SEXISM OF THE '50s, SIMPLY SO
THEY CAN FEEL LIKE THEY ARE
VICTIMS.
PREPOSTEROUS.
I AM NOT A VICTIM.
I DON'T KNOW ANY FEMALE VICTIMS,
FRANKLY.
THERE IS A SENSE THAT IN ORDER
FOR FEMALES TO SUCCEED, IT HAS
TO BE AT THE EXPENSE OF MALES
AND THROUGH A CONSTANT DEVALUE